[Music]
no one is immune from the ravages of
time the detrimental effects of aging
are inevitable right but what if we
could turn back the clock and replace
worn-out or damaged body parts with
completely new ones it may sound like
science fiction but researchers studying
cell growth are currently working to
make it science fact imagine a future of
where no one waits on an organ
transplant honest if your kidney failed
you could have a replacement made to
order in the lab using your own cells
technicians could build a new kidney
using a 3d printer and with this printed
organ you'd quickly get back to a
productive life imagine a future where
if you're disfigured in an unfortunate
accident a pill could change the
electrical charge at the site of the
injury causing your toes to regenerate
and in the future if you suffer from
heart failure a new organ could be grown
on a cadaver heart scaffold using your
own stem cells and with this new heart
you could get back to running
[Music]
while these three futuristic treatments
are only in the experimental stage there
is one science fiction sounding therapy
that is already being used on humans
take the case of Marine Sergeant Brian
Smith who was injured while leading his
squad down one of the most treacherous
roads in Fallujah Iraq I was on a
mission to get my squad familiar with
the new area of operation that were and
that entailed traveling down IND alley
Smith's Humvee struck an AED or
improvised explosive device we're just
traveling and then all of a sudden we
got hit and I believe I went out for a
second a piece of shrapnel sliced
through the tricep and bicep of his
right arm severing a major artery and
leaving his muscles in tatters and I
realized I couldn't move my right arm at
first I thought it was gone but I could
feel that it was still there and I could
feel the blood my blood from my artery
pumping into my hand as I reached over
sergeant Smith was airlifted to Germany
for treatment back in the u.s.
rehabilitation of his arm left him weak
unable to assist with the care of his
nine month old son he was go go go go
one of the issues is trying to care for
him I couldn't pick him I couldn't pick
him up if he's squirming because I only
had one hand couldn't change him because
you know you want one hand to try to
keep the kids still Brian compensated
for the weakness by using the strength
in his back two years later he was able
to join the Bangor police force but that
weakness in his arm was always on his
mind my concerns about my arm was
anything that required pulling they're
trying to take somebody into custody
sometimes you have to pry their arm out
they'd have to do in my right hand but I
knew I was now significantly weaker in
that hand first my left hand
Brian heard about an experimental
procedure at the University of
Pittsburgh that uses an extracellular
matrix to regrow damaged muscle tissue a
year after treatment in 2013 things were
remarkably different with his arm
[Music]
the big thing is I was able to hold my
child and my right arm longer than I
ever have Brian had lost 1/3 of his
bicep with ECM he was able to regrow
almost all of the missing muscle tissue
today my arm feels great my endurance is
there that was that was the that's the
big thing for me now Brian can do his
job with complete confidence and be the
hands-on father he wanted to be being
forever young the future and the promise
of human regeneration so without further
ado let's meet our scientists beginning
with the director of regenerative
medicine research and director Center
for cell and organ biotechnology at the
Texas Heart Institute in Houston she
also holds faculty appointments at Texas
A&M and Rice University please welcome
Doris Taylor our next guest is a
professor in the Department of Surgery
and deputy director of the McGowan
Institute for regenerative medicine at
the University of Pittsburgh
dr. battle-ax is a past president of the
tissue engineering regenerative medicine
International Society please welcome
Steven battle at
also joining us is a principal
investigator in the Tufts Center for
regenerative and developmental biology
and research professor in the department
of biology at Tufts University
she is also faculty in the ebooks
program at MIT and a member of the Alan
Discovery Center at Tufts please welcome
Danny Spencer Adams our final guest is
an associate professor and associate
director of the Nancy II and Peter sea
mining School of biomedical engineering
at Cornell University and beautiful
Ithaca he's been recognized with awards
given by the Society for heart valve
disease and the biomedical engineering
Society please welcome Jonathan butcher
welcome so we want to start tonight's
conversation by asking each of you
beginning with Danny just to give us a
little bit of a primer if you will on
exactly what you're working on well I
actually came to study regeneration
through studying generation and I
believe you're about to see a movie that
I made showing the generation of a face
in a frog embryo so there you're looking
at a frog embryo right now and that
bright spot coming up over the horizon
like that is actually the central
nervous system forming and you're going
to see spots that are making where the
face is going to be and what those spots
are is they're a dye that's showing us
where the cells are more negative on the
inside than they are on the outside so
it's an electrical characteristic of the
cells and what we found by studying
these developmental processes is that
these electrical signals help the embryo
know where to put things and very
importantly how to shape things and that
turns out to be a very very important
aspect of generative regeneration which
is how do you get the proper shape for
function and shape turns out to be
important we're going to come back to
that Steven how how did you come to
actually grow muscle tissue tell us
about this our approach is a little
different to regenerative medicine and
as you saw in sergeant Smith there we
our intent is to provide the environment
that the body normally uses to send
signals to say okay stem cells come on
over here form this particular type of
tissue or these cells should proliferate
in other words we it's sort of like the
movie you know build it and they will
come so that's we want to do is provide
the micro environment what's called the
extracellular matrix and then let the
body do the rest of the work so it's a
little different approach but it seems
to be working
Doris you you have a different approach
altogether tell us about that well heart
disease is a number one killer of men
women and children so what we've done
for the last 20 years is working ways to
repair the damage in the heart we
started with genes but what we realized
is that you had to get lucky and picked
the right gene and that cells were
little gene factories so we moved to
cells but if you're gonna put a cell in
the heart just like Steve said it needs
a right environment and so it's probably
not it's probably true that we're never
gonna get enough cells to take a fully
damaged leathery thin scar and make it
into healthy heart again so what we said
is wow we need an environment let's take
a heart let's give nature the tools and
get out of the way so today I work on
building a heart in the lab by taking
stem cells and putting them in what we
call a ghost heart a heart where we've
already stripped all the cells to let
nature provide those cues to rebuild the
heart amazing amazing Jonathan I think
even more amazing or equally as amazing
is printing a heart valve how does one
begin to even think about printing a
heart valve well so I think I came into
this approach as a traditional
mechanical engineer like Danny I heard a
lecture on developmental biology of the
heart and this this biologist proceeded
to describe how the heart forms inside
of a week in this animal and
Here I am trying to engineer something
to change a protein in months and so
clearly there was so much natural
engineering going on that we didn't
understand and so I sort of shifted
training into developmental biology and
and then now in my my current lab we'd
combine both of those sets of tools to
be able to try to bio fabricate these
organs well let's let's get to the idea
of actually how you are doing this and
what what this stuff actually looks like
so Doris take us through the how to make
a heart if you will well you know you
can do this at home that's right there
are blocks about how to do this online
and and I think I think that illustrates
an amazing point that that people really
want to understand the science of this
and the biology of this and there's such
an unmet need I think I had a high
school kid call me last week and say our
family's barbecuing a pig in the yard
and and my family gave me the heart and
it's in the refrigerator what do I do
I told her I said tell us I said we do
so what do you do yeah well if you're
gonna build a hurt you need cells pretty
neat but beating cells right here in the
dish aren't enough to make a heart you
need a place to put those cells see me a
framework or a scaffold so what we did
is we took the heart a pig heart or any
a human heart we now work routinely with
human hearts and we wash the cells out
we use baby shampoo literally to wash
the cells out of the heart and you can
see here on the video a pig heart in
this case with no cells so so what can
that do I mean what is it it's the
extracellular matrix as proteins
proteins okay if you touch it feels a
little bit like a jello wiggler and for
those of you aren't old enough to know
that jello wiggler is it it's dehydrated
jello it's actually pretty tough but we
can then put
sells back into that heart okay and when
we put cells back in what's so amazing
is you put a blood vessel cell in and it
goes to the blood vessel you put a heart
muscle cell in it goes to the muscle we
call it our smart heart it knows what to
do here you see a heart where we've put
cells back in and it's pink now because
it's beginning to be more muscle and
it's moving because you can't just put a
stem cell in a heart and let it sit
there it has to act like a heart look
like a heart and work like a heart no
one to do to grow up and become a heart
so it has to have a blood pressure it
has to have lungs and oxygen this is a
human heart in one of our bio reactors
well what is that sound so bioreactor is
basically an artificial body it's got
blood it's got oxygen it's got
temperature and it's got an immune
system so we and you see here the
plastic container that's the bioreactor
keeps it sterile keeps it warm food
clothing shelter everything you need to
build a heart so we put stem cells back
in and they mature over time if we give
them the right keys it it's pretty
remarkable and you can do it with
anything heart liver kidney lung
pancreas believable Steven tell us your
story how are you doing what are you
doing to get muscle well what we do is
start with the matrix and again back to
the matrix that's right and the it's a
matter of week it you can isolate every
tissue in the body of every person in
this audience has extracellular matrix
around the cells that's the scaffolding
material and in this video what you see
is Scott in my lab that's a that's a pig
bladder that that you can go to the the
slaughterhouse and pick up and instead
of them it's an it's a byproduct of the
agricultural industry that would have
been fertilizer or food or something
else
we didn't pick it up and we take away
the muscle layers and were left with
only the layers that we want and so
that's that's the thin layer that Scott
was holding up there and then we we take
out all of the cells and what you're
left with is this friendly inductive
material endorses case it was a
three-dimensional heart in our case it's
this simple sheet of material that we
can keep as a sheet we could turn it
into a hydrogel we could turn it into a
liquid and you're looking at muscle
cells there that were formed in and it
wasn't Sargent Smith's
but one of our other patients in a
recent study where we treated 13
patients like sergeant Smith all of whom
returned to a quality of life where they
could do the activities of daily living
like he did
so we basically what we do is change the
default that this material has the
ability to signal the body to say look
instead of responding to this injury by
forming a scar what we want to do is
recruit the body's own cells to it and
have them assemble as doris was saying
the way that they would normally and and
recreate the tissue rather than just
repair the tissue so it's a little
different approach and like I said it's
none of us have the solution to all the
problems but we all get there a little
different way absolutely
Danny you're using electricity is that
fair to saying to make so that sounds
Frankenstein Ian I love the analogy the
the idea is that by studying these these
electrical signals during development
and seeing that they can be the signal
that says okay you be a muscle cell
these cells start dividing those cells
stop dividing that this is one of the
ways that cells talk to each other so
chemicals is one important way but
electricity is another important way and
it's the move it's just the movement of
ions so everybody it's heard of pH which
is it's just a fancy way of saying the
concentration of hydrogen ions and
hydrogen ions moving that's a current
that's electricity
and we found that there are so many
places in in development of the embryo
where those electrical signals seem to
be hesitate to use the term but it
master switches they really do seem to
be like you flip a switch and then a
process gets started and very
importantly it doesn't just get started
it gets controlled and it gets stopped
at the right time so we then so you say
okay well will this work in regeneration
as well and have found that yes again in
that situation it's these very very
powerful signals that that coordinate
they take care of everything what you're
seeing here actually is one of the
really important stages in vertebrates
of things with backbones in in
regeneration of vertebrates is that you
have to have nerves there for the rest
of the structure to regenerate what
you're looking at here is a lot of
nerves that have grown places where they
don't normally belong that's that that's
a close-up of a thin of a tadpole of a
frog
and this is work by dr. Douglas
Blackistone and what he did to get that
to happen was he simply soaked the
embryo sorry so the tadpole in serotonin
so the neurotransmitter and what happens
through a chemical signaling pathway is
that the serotonin makes the cells in
that fin be a little more positive than
they would normally be and that attracts
the nerves and so a place with no nerve
suddenly has this this huge invasion by
all these nerves he's actually done some
truly remarkable work where he has it's
a combination of transplant but then
looking at what happens to the nerves
and he has he puts a piece of tissue
that would be an eye and he puts it into
the the flank of another embryo so puts
it in the wrong place
and uses and I because that will then
send out a large nerve the optic nerve
and sometimes that optic nerve actually
finds its way to the spinal cord and
that I can sense light it can see so the
brain somehow knows that its visual
information even though it's coming from
all the wrong place but again it's this
this idea of being able to control and
and use those electrical signals to get
what we need to happen in this case for
nerves to grow and in other cases for
entire limbs to reproduce themselves
show us what that so what you're looking
at here is the back end of a frog and if
a frog loses a limb what you see here is
the one that is the the left hand side
that's a completely regenerated limb so
that was amputated up close to the knee
there and normally if that happens you
get what's called a spike and it's just
a exactly what it sounds like it's a
spike but this was treated this was work
of dr. Ison ting when she was working
with Mike Levin and she treated that
wound with a little cocktail and that
cocktail did the same thing it made the
cells change their electrical
characteristics and six months later
this grew back so instead of getting a
spike she got a foot and this is a foot
it has you can see the blood vessels
it's got skin it's got muscle it's got
bone and very importantly it has nerves
and it's also the right shape and what
you're seeing here is something she's
just poking that to show you that it's
quite responsive it has a very
well-formed and functional nervous
system so this incredibly simple message
months ago which was change your
electrical potential and this entire
limb has grown back and it's the right
shape and it stops when it's done
unbelievable it's quite extraordinary
work now so give us the jonathan the how
to print a heart-valve for dummies if
you will well i mean i think we're all
aware of this this new revolution of 3d
printing and and there's these maker
communities and maker spaces and all
sorts of printers that are not entering
the you know the community for the
ability to make almost anything and i
say almost because making something
that's completely living is very
different than making something out of
plastic but in reality anybody who has
ever made a birthday cake can 3d print
something that is as complex as as a
heart valve i would say the the way that
we need to do it differently is because
every patient has a different heart
valve and that or I mean or heart or you
know whatever but that geometric
complexity is actually extremely
important for that particular success of
that particular graph for that patient
so what we have to do is work with
surgeons to get the clinical imaging
which you see here that defines the
actual geometry needed to extract and
then replicate in a 3d printer now once
you have that geometry you can actually
use computer algorithms to develop a
deposition or printing path and you can
use a printer like the one you see here
to essentially deposit material along
those two fine paths now the challenge
then becomes well what do you print
because it's not gonna be frosting or
plastic so we actually develop in our
lab these materials we could call them
living inks or slurries and they're
actually comprised of biologically
derived components of extracellular
matrix potentially from tissues like the
ones that Doris and Steven are talking
about but also we can make them from
scratch and the idea is that you can
design point by point what material you
want where and also we can embed
cells in those same environments and the
opportunity is that now you can put the
instructions that you want to give cells
in each location so that in one location
they make one type of cell and another
location they the stem cells turn into a
different type of cell all the while
achieving the geometric complexity and
that is that's yes so that's a human
it's an aortic heart valve a tri leaflet
heart valve that we've that we've
manufactured and you can see a couple
different sizes that we make here
because one of the major clinical needs
for this type of technology is actually
pediatric populations in particular for
a scaffold a graph like this that has
the living capacity to grow and so it's
you can't really use a prosthetic for
that so there's really nothing other
than this kind of an opportunity to go
so that's why we're pushing this
envelope okay
so what one of the things that I think
we have to talk about is the elephant in
the room which is genetics and genomics
and that's an inside joke so what there
is a paradigm shift here because you
guys aren't doing anything with genes
you're you're using like a more you're
coming at it from a completely different
angle tell me about the paradigm shift
and how it happened and what it means
well to me
genes as I said earlier if you're gonna
work with genes you have to know the
right gene and you have to have a cell
for that gene to work genes don't happen
in a vacuum they only work in a cell so
we said we can spend the rest of our
lives trying to pick the right gene
figure out the right gene or we can take
cells which are little gene factories
and let nature drive which genes by
providing the right environment for
those genes whether it's Kim for those
cells whether it's chemical as scaffold
or whatever genes are the potential
cells are the reality okay
Stephen well the I pretty much agree
with with the door so I think I'm a
little more positive on the future of
using the human genome and our
understanding of molecular biology for
personalized medicine because each of us
has our own unique set of genes and I
think the more that we understand about
you know your your set versus my set you
know one particular therapy is going to
work better for you than it is going for
me that I think that's where we're going
to really use that particular approach
to regenerative medicine but the as we
one of the things I find the most
interesting about what we do and what
makes my job so much fun every day is
you know when we put an extracellular
matrix either in a petri dish or in a
patient why do certain cells get
attracted what tell what signals in that
matrix tell that stem cell that you
should now differentiate into you know a
bone or cartilage or whatever and it
gets down to the molecular signals that
are there so what are those signaling
pathways you know an interesting fight
here's a real life example and without
getting into too much detail we now
understand how why can you take a pig
extracellular matrix put it into a human
and not have problems right why doesn't
it get rejected so we're very interested
in that question one of the reasons is
because the molecular makeup of the
proteins and the other molecules have
formed my extracellular matrix and yours
and a pig's and a mouse and probably a
dinosaur is so similar that that the
recipient says okay you might not be me
but you're not so bad you know you're I
think I I think I understand you know
you know what your thoughts so we don't
reject it and then actually it breaks it
down them and it's loaded with these
signaling molecules and so one of the
things we found out in a recent study
because we were interested in the immune
system was what what tells the immune
system to accept and not reject lepay
well the intracellular pathway involves
the same pathway that is inhibited by
non-steroidal anti-inflammatory
NSAIDs like I had
Naprosyn things like this so what we
learned is that if you put the patient
on these non-steroidal drugs after
surgery for pain you're actually
blocking a pathway that's important so
from that standpoint it's really
important yes it is yeah or yeah if you
were I'm even sorry that word exists
because it implies a negative
connotation and without inflammation you
know we don't none of us would be here
summation is nature's cue to say I've
got an injury send me cells yeah so
let's finish with one more comment
because Jonathan's an engineer you know
Danny's and molecular biologist I'm a
physician and doors is everything and
then and then so but none of us have the
answer the an interdisciplinary approach
to these problems of using the molecular
biologists and the engineering and such
is where the greatest advances are going
to be made you know at one of our
problems is that were so our method of
educating is is its ancient and it
hasn't changed much but we are
recognized in interdisciplinary
approaches to problems yield the biggest
solutions before we get too far away
from from the genome and genetics is one
reason we don't study it is because
there are lots of people studying it and
there's there's doing tremendous
wonderful work and that's not what we're
interested in but that's all being done
but really beautifully in labs all over
the world but the other part of that is
it hasn't worked yet
we don't what he's taking no one's damn
cell and turned it into a heart nobody
has said these genes are the things that
give you this shape got it and in fact
there there are these very people now
work on things called gene regulatory
networks and these are genes that turn
each other on and off and trying to
figure it out what what is actually
going on who's the message passing from
- like a game of telephone almost
and you can have the gene regulatory
networks
you could think of as a map and they
have you know one map that has 50
different things in it gives you a tube
that's a blood blood vessel but if you
have another tube that's for dump
something different the gene regulatory
network could be completely different
there's nothing in there yet we don't
know yet how to look at that and see
where a shape actually comes from and
that's because it doesn't in it it
doesn't we haven't yet figured out how
to bring in geometry and forces and
directing forces and resisting them and
generating them and it just simply
hasn't worked yet
don't you think Nature has developed a
lot of different ways though to create
the same things absolutely if you look
at it we have tubes and in our blood
vessels we have tubes and our in our
lungs we have tubes in our kidney in our
bladder and you know our tubes
everything right so the body the body
has created there are a number of
different ways to create every single
thing that exists so it's not one gene
one endpoint and and I think what we're
doing is say at least my view of it is
we're bypassing a lot of that and we're
saying we've got the shape we're letting
nature we're taking advantage of what
nature's already built with those cues
already in it and letting that drive
what we decide to do going forward so we
we can spend the next twenty years
figuring out all those networks or we
can use what nature's built and go
forward Steven did you want after that
well you know I was just gonna I was
trying to figure out how to get this
comment in but maybe just give me an
opening the developmental biology if we
don't understand normal development how
do we expect to develop effective
strategies for recreating normal
functional tissue so we have a couple of
regenerative organs in our body the
liver
constantly regenerating by a mechanism
that's different than the axolotl but
it's a regenerative our bone marrow
regenerates all our blood cells every
day our skin outer layers of our skin
and one or two other tissues but
agrestic but through evolution the rest
of our tissues have changed to say what
we've sacrificed regeneration for
healing for scar tissue formation and
it's really interesting I think in
developmental biology if you look at
human fetus in the first trimester can
regenerate all sorts of organs and
somewhere around 16 to 18 weeks of
gestation right when our immune system
kicks in we need we develop this ability
to fight off infection and to respond to
injury we lose the ability to regenerate
so what genes are being turned on which
genes are being turned off and I think
if we just would work together a little
more Danny that's an important point
that there's a a roadmap there for
regeneration that could be understood
better but and you know you can think
about that even as even after we're born
though if you look at a two-year-old and
they fall down and scrape their knee
they it's gonna get red that
inflammation is gonna happen and that's
gonna be nature's cue to say send me
more cells and they get they heal that
but they probably don't have a scar for
the rest of their life
two-year-old gets cold it goes away in
three days they've got cells and they've
got potent healthy cells that we don't
have when you're 50 to 60 - you fall
down you scrape your knee there's
actually cues aren't the same there's a
wonderful story about that actually that
up to about the age of seven and
depending on tells you who tells you the
story it's five sometimes it's ten but
when you're a kid you can actually lose
the tip of your finger and generally the
standard procedure then is to take skin
and wrap it over to prevent infection
but if you don't do that there is a
current called the healing current and
it's just positive charges leaving the
tip of the cell tip of the finger and
the finger will regenerate and it'll
regenerate the bone and the skin and the
muscle and that and the nail and we lose
that ability
you know somewhere 710 something like
that but what that tells us and the
liver and all these things it tells us
that that ourselves do know how to do
this and we can either can do that for
two weeks after birth for two weeks so
all of our cells seem to know that it's
in there somewhere
and whether we need genetics to trigger
it
if we can help them along I know that
some people now one of the correct me
but isn't one of the treatments for
losing a finger tip is to pack the wound
with the pig bladder right to provide
the scaffold so there's there's learning
how it's done there's learning how we
might be able to manipulate it to
trigger it now whether that's exactly
the way it was done when the embryo was
developing and turning into a fetus or
whether we do it by you know checking it
turning on the wrong gene but it has the
right effect that's where that turns
into medicine that's where you go to
translation and how do we we don't care
how it was done we care how to make it
happen again let's talk about what are
some of the actual term and near-term
benefits of what we're talking about
tonight who where do where do we see
things if not right now very soon
Jonathan well I mean I think the the
things that are right now are the kinds
of things you saw in the movie here and
the kinds of things that Steve's doing
with being able to augment Nate the
human's own capacity to heal in weather
whether it's regenerating a tip of your
finger or healing a certain injury
better like a diabetic ulcer or
something like that I think in the in
the more near term we're going to see
and there's a lot of trials going on
right now in the in this space for
tissues that perform an important role
say an Occupational role but they're not
essential for life like for example a
vertebral disc or a knee meniscus or
some
like this this is the area that I think
will be the first place where we're
going to start to see some of these you
know tissue engineering strategies
biofabrication come into play Danny what
about where right now what do you see
using your electric electrodes right now
we see amazing possibilities I think
we're still far from it
but in some ways we may be able to skip
more quickly than other types of
therapies from you know making frog do
it to making a human do it and the
reason for that is there are so many
drugs that are already available there's
some of them are over-the-counter that
the what those drugs target are these
proteins that make electrical things
happen so if you've ever taken a proton
pump inhibitor for you know stomach acid
the proton pump is a protein and it
moves hydrogen ions which are protons
from inside the cells outside the cell
and that you know just when when I was
working with tadpole tail regeneration
we found that all you had to do to get
the entire tail to regenerate was give
it a message and we did that in a number
of different ways but give it the
message pump protons and we got the
entire tail so we have drugs that you
can take now and that pump protons or
they stop something they stop your
proton pumps from pumping their
inhibitors I told the story about
serotonin having can having this this
tremendous effect via its effect on the
electrical status of the cells
well prozac is can have the same kind of
effect we have all these drugs their
targets are these electrical signals so
in some ways it could be very rapid
because we already have the medications
but we do have a long way to go in terms
of understanding for any given organ
that you lose you have heart damage we
don't know oh well yeah if you take
prilosec your heart will grow back we
don't know that yet but but we're
getting there it won't so it's possible
that once we really decipher that
language we can and we can speak it we
can start going in there and fixing the
grammar and it would be potentially as
easy as taking a pill Doris I'll get to
you less but I what your day-to-day is
kind of using these applications is that
correct yeah yeah tell us tell us how
you do that we've got between eight and
ten million patients have been treated
with an extracellular matrix scaffold
but most of them are for rather ordinary
everyday things and there's there's good
reasons for that like hernia repair
instead of using a synthetic mess made
out of polypropylene you would make it
out of extracellular matrix and and
these were used for that for that now
yeah 20 years ago they they didn't exist
though those sorts of scaffold materials
didn't exist same thing it's used for
the lining of the brain to replace that
so there's lots of those everyday things
and the reason those things got to the
clinic so quickly was because the
they're regulated as a device by the by
the FDA they were they were promoted in
a non regenerative medicine approach
rather than simply say hey look we've
just got a different type of mesh
material for you so it gets out there
and now I've got all these patients
treated one more thing cause it's an
aspect of it that isn't scientific but
you might not think of in terms of
yy-you don't see more clinical
translation when you have when you have
a regenerative medicine approach that is
significantly different than the
standard of care and even though you're
absolutely convinced it works you can
point to all of these studies you go
into and you have a patient that walks
through the door and you want to use
that and you do go ahead and use it your
your colleagues are looking at you
saying what are you doing you can't you
know you don't you know we've been
taught
to treat these patients aren't you you
know this is so you've got peer pressure
to say don't do it and then you've got
how are you going to get it reimbursed
because you got a you got a solution
here but there's no way to pay for that
right now
and until you prove it you know ten
years later after this money that and
then on top of that you've got lawyers
standing out there waiting to see you
the first time anything goes wrong I
mean so what are the incentives to do
these you've got your colleagues saying
no you're not going to get paid for it
you're at risk of getting sued and yet
your patient said please you know not
that's really that's as big a barrier as
a scientific barriers for translating
regenerative medicine and that's the the
heartache of being an innovator right
being someone who is outside the box and
not in the mainstream which probably I
think all of you maybe Jonathan a little
less than others have have faced a
little ostracism is that fair to say yes
of course right right what about your
doors well and then we'll talk about
money because we promise we're gonna
discuss yeah the thing about
regenerative medicine is it's unlike any
other treatment in that in that when you
give it you know you give a drug it's
gonna wear off you give a drug it may
have an effect you know and when you
don't
apparently proton pump inhibitors grow
salamander tails inside you I don't want
that but but but the point is with
regenerative medicine strategies there
forever so when you give them you have
to know they work you have to know
they're going to hang around for the
long time long term and be safe and you
have to know that that they're going to
actually be flexible and and change as
the individual changes or faces other
issues so the burden is higher for these
than any other therapy that exists at
the same time the potential is huge
right now we may not be able
to build a heart in a lab but I predict
within the next two to three years we'll
see a kid will see a liver be built and
transplanted into a patient we will see
I you will see a liver beyond that
pancreas is being built
lelou you know of long as being built
we're gonna see these happen but even
today we can build a cardiac patch we
can build new blood vessels we can build
a lot of tissues that are simple tubes
those tubes we were talking about
earlier bladder there are new cosmetic
ears there are a number of strategies
that already exist
and for and I would go so far as to say
we're not building organs and tissues
we're building hope we're building that
the future and the the potential for us
to actually do what we're talking about
here foreveryoung where we're building
the potential to keep people healthy
longer and able to function at a level
that they haven't been able to before I
think something to keep in mind too is
the people said well what are we going
to do if we can solve all these problems
and live to be a hundred and twenty or
on I don't want to live to be a hundred
and you don't want to hear me talking
about the same thing for another you
know X number of years it's a but so I
we frequently say but you want to be
healthy
healthy is quality not quantity and I
think we'd all like to live to be eighty
eighty-five and functional have all our
faculties up until you know a couple
days before we go right and then you're
then you're going then I know that's
fine not a they can all go at once
everything happens on you know in the
single usable part left right but you're
helping until a week ahead of time so
it's quality not quantity I don't think
we want to live forever so let's let's
just make a couple predictions here it's
2025
what's out there Bob's body parts
off-the-shelf heart valves you know what
am I tell me what the future is Doris
what are we gonna see I think in by 2025
if man is still alive wasn't that a song
if we're not you know right trying to
make it on waters
III really think that we're going to
begin to see off-the-shelf organs and
tissues for for Trent we're gonna solve
the organ transplant problem at least
the liver and kidney and lung transplant
problem I also believe that we're going
to change our endogenous repair
processes so that the future is not ever
getting to the point that you need that
organ we're gonna learn how to how to
use these cells earlier use stem cells
that we all have in every organ and
tissue and and really maximize our
endogenous capacity for repair to keep
us from having to have long-term chronic
disease and then I think we will be
printing I think we will be you know put
the four of us in a room and don't let
us out for six months and and Steven and
Daniel get the get those limbs built as
far as the bioelectrical control eight
years is not a long time to figure it
out but I think that the combination if
once the electrical signals we have a
better sense of how they work they will
become a very important part of the
bioreactor into which these the the the
personalized printed organs are going to
go or the hearts that that that's going
to be the first step of bringing that
into it is going to be to bring these
things together I mean thinking about
this culture that we're talking about in
eight years I mean I would love it if we
could see engineers becoming an integral
part of the health care engine so the
way I see this though is sort of like
what you were saying we have the printer
in the o.r right or you're thinking
about using clinical imaging to create
data to inform surgical approach should
I go this way or this way instead of
opening up the patient is saying well
gosh what should I do now you actually
have the information ahead of time and
you may actually have a model of it or a
hologram you can stare at you know I
mean we know about robotic surgery but
like that's a big device there's a whole
lot of ways to to sort of democratize
this approach where every hospital has
the capacity to integrate with you know
well-trained people that can help the
doctor in their approach perhaps help
them provide a better graft I mean so
many of the medical revolutions that
have happened that we know about in
prosthetic industries whatever was
doctors reaching for something around
the o.r because they got this thing
going on with his patient and that
turned into a medical device well if you
have an engineer that's actually
involved in that process you could maybe
have some a lot more transformative
components but you know that also comes
down to in that culture thinking about
like what what Steve said in terms of
reimbursement how does that piece get
get paid for I mean I think this is a
big component to thinking about the
overall federal strategy of supporting
research when you try to translate this
research maybe there's a way of thinking
about how citizens can can get in on
this new technology but how do we share
this risk how do we share this knowledge
space in a way that isn't you know sort
of a pendulum swinging of everybody
getting the latest thing and then
everybody suing and you know there's
there's a potential here to put more
pieces on the table we don't talk about
you know as a dirty little secret in
Sciences we're all taught that if we
don't bring in our own grants and our
own money then we're not successful that
if you if I work with you and I help you
bring in grants and it doesn't count for
me so part of what has to change is the
recognition that science is a team sport
and institutions have to value that team
mentality or it's never gonna happen
one of the things we talked about
offline before we began
evening was funding and this for
scientists and biomedical scientists
bioengineers like yourselves this is a
very big issue tell me what some of your
concerns are Doris do you want to what I
mean science funding has it has gotten
has gone down over the last two decades
and about five years ago it was at the
lowest it had ever been in my lifetime
building one heart one human sized heart
cost me about two hundred thousand
dollars and until we get it
reproducible and simple it's gonna keep
costing two hundred thousand dollars
will the NIH and an average NIH grant
it's two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars a year that's one heart a year
it's not gonna get us they're very fast
if there's if there's one thing you
could say or do what would it be to
ensure that funding continues science
isn't technology we don't say I'm gonna
go in and discover that electrical
signals can trigger regeneration you go
in and you spend for it so that movie
the electric face movie it took me four
years it was an accident
the the microscope where I made the
movie is a 250 thousand dollar
microscope that's I didn't go in one day
and say I'm gonna make this movie it's
not engineering it's not problem solving
and you can't put in a grant on this
date I will have the crucial insight but
there are some private foundations now
that are doing things in a different way
and I I want to shout out actually for
Templeton which has just awarded a
fellowship to one of Michael Evans
postdocs to continue this frog leg
regeneration study and to the Paul G
Allen Family Foundation which is trying
a different approach which is to pick
out a person and in this case Michael
Evan was one of those people who and bet
on their creativity
and their productivity and basically say
here is all the money you need so you
don't have to spend 60 to 80% of your
time writing grants instead of doing
experiments take this and see what you
can come up with and I think that's a
very important and useful approach okay
we're gonna take a few questions from
the audience Charlotte age 12 has I
think a really great question could we
improve upon nature making larger
muscles or a stronger ACL and could you
do this for an extinct species oh man I
don't think you I don't the question
Charlotte yes it was a good question and
we could ask that a lot because of the
work we're doing with the muscle stuff
but I don't think we can ever improve
upon mother nature that's if we don't
even understand mother nature you know
it's it but what we can do is hopefully
harness all that some of the signals
that she's got to to take advantage of
what Mother Nature does so well and so
to make a superhuman no I don't I don't
think we want to do that first of all
but I don't think we can do it in like
in the example with the salamander why
does it stop growing and what gets to
here you know every time you know and
when we would actually tried some of
these experiments where we would we knew
we can grow up grow new muscle let's put
a do it again do more and you can then
temporarily it will grow more but then
when the body doesn't need it it just it
regresses back to to normal the but it's
just so smart I mean it's just it is
just it just makes me realize how little
we understand about mileage I wrote a a
perspective piece of a couple of months
ago called too much technology not
enough biology so the technology and the
printing and such as fantastic but if we
don't know what we want to print we
can't do it that that was why bino came
out so quickly but but that was at the
extinct species piece we can actually
take DNA and we can actually begin to
create tissues from extinct species I'm
not sure you know like we said early
everything as an effect you know and
when you don't I'm not sure we want to
yet but we could if I can just build on
that I mean one of the the idea that
there is an optimal muscle is is I think
oversimplifying so one of the things
that evolution does evolution has to
balance competing needs so and for
reasons we don't know yet it may be that
if a muscle gets too big you know your
toes fall off I mean I don't but there's
a there is a trade off that we don't
know about and that if we try if we pick
out something that we happen to like and
say oh I'm gonna optimize that you you
simply don't know what you're putting at
the same time the same muscle you used
to build a fly wing that can do
something phenomenal would not work in a
human I mean well that's that's that
leads great into the next question from
Erika the redhead she writes do you
think regeneration can be used to
replace or fix damaged cells in cases
like cancers or in autoimmune disorders
absolutely absolutely
the one thing stem cells do better than
anything is reduce inflammation
absolutely no question well there's
something uncomfortably close about what
you guys are doing and and the in cancer
the concept of is on so what's a chancer
cell what's a cancer cell cancer cells a
cell that can become a lot of different
things and also that that reproduces
what's a stem cell it's a cell that
reproduces and can become a lot of
different things the difference is we a
cancer cell doesn't know when to stop
and and some of us have believed that
some tumors are actually stem cells gone
bad so I think the I think really
understanding that interaction is
critical none of us want to build that
muscle that is now a tumor
one Scene tumorous or cancerous
unchecked growth in the labs yeah how do
you tell us Alice how do you tell us L
is a true stem cell true pluripotent can
become anything stem cell you transplant
it and you watch it make a tumor it's
not a cancerous tumor but its tumor
it's a teratoma unchecked growth
teratomas are actually there there are
perfect illustration of this issue of
shape being so important so teratomas
for those who don't know are they are
tumors that form often from the cells
that make eggs for example and there are
and they and they the cells start to
become different tissues so but they
don't know how to get into the right
shape so what you end up with is like a
blob of tissue that's growing hair and
some of its cells are producing stomach
acid and they're they're they're truly
horrifying they have teeth sometimes the
cells are following the right path to
become a tissue and it's called
differentiation is the big word for it
but they are differentiating into
different cell types just as their genes
are telling them to do but they have
completely lost any information about
what shape they're supposed to be and so
it's a blob of tissue right cell types
so but I want to go back for a second
because cancer regeneration development
these are all we we look at all of these
things from that perspective of Ken the
electricals Ken looking at the
electrical signals teach us something
that we haven't learned by looking at
the chemical signals that are controlled
by the genes and one of the one of the
amazing and another amazing thing about
electricity is that we can generate
tumors genetically so we can inject a
tumor causing a cancer causing mutant
gene and at the same
I'm inject the gene for a protein that
will allow potassium ions in sorry the
potassium ions out and what happens is
the tumor doesn't form so the potassium
current changes the electrical status of
the cell and that tumor causing gene
can't form a tumor the other thing that
you can do is you can put in a gene for
there's this amazing thing called
optogenetics I'm not going to go into it
right now but basically into detail but
these are proteins that you turn them on
and off by shining light on them and if
you if you make one of these tumors by
injecting the mutant gene and you also
inject the gene for one of these light
activated channels you can wait till the
tumor forms then you turn on the light
and the tumor goes away and this were in
this in frogs this works better than
most of our cancer drugs so again this
connection between the electrical
signals the way the cells are talking to
each other in this context of generating
a shape controlling the shape making a
structure it's it's again I think it's
it's this it's just really powerful go
home and sank your electrical I think I
think I think you she brings up a good
point though also with another
opportunity for engineering and that is
to create models of patient's actual
tumors for example and instead of
testing the drugs effectiveness on the
patient why don't we do it on these
tumors that are the patient's tumor yeah
no I agree but like one of this the new
strategies that is gaining traction a
lot of different tumors is to actually
differentiate it so instead of having
this cancerous tumor turn it into a pile
of bone well if I have a pile of bones
sitting somewhere that's a lot better
than a tumor because now it's just
sitting there as a chunk of bone but you
could test that out in a set of
engineered tumors so that you wouldn't
have to worry about trying it out on the
patient alright I got I got two more
questions
I have everybody wants to know when is
this heart gonna happen
give me five years okay you got five
years and finally and this is also you
get to pick one which Marvel hero is
more likely to be realized by research
Wolverine who's healing or Deadpool
regeneration what do you pick Jonathan
oh I'm gonna go Wolverine okay
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Wolverine okay Wolverine okay
Deadpool thank you all for coming thank
you to our amazing scientist
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]